ليس من الصواب
ألا يتحدث أي منهما عن
حقوق الإنسان في فلسطين
أن الأطفال في فلسطين يتعرضون
للقتل وأن أيًا من هذه
الأطراف لن يتحدث عن أن هذا ليس
جيدًا ، فلا يمكنك
اختيار حقوق الإنسان واختيارها.  لا يمكنك أن
تختار أن
الأشخاص الذين يُقتلون
بدرجاتهم من أجل حماية البيئة أقل من الأشخاص الآخرين ، فلا يمكنك
اختيار أن
الأويغور لا يهمهم لأن لدينا
علاقة اقتصادية مع الصين
ليس كيف تعمل حقوق
الإنسان وكل واحد منا في هذا المكان إذا كنا
نؤمن بحماية حقوق الإنسان ،
فإن حق الإنسان هو
حق من حقوق الإنسان ، ولا يهم إذا كان
طفلاً في فلسطين ، فلا يهم إذا
إنه طفل في اليمن ، لا يهم
إذا كانت امرأة في شينجيانغ ، فلا
يهم إذا كانت امرأة في أوكرانيا إذا كانت
لدينا سياسة خارجية نسوية إذا كنا
نؤمن بحقوق الإنسان ، كل حقوق الإنسان
تهمني وأنا كذلك.  خائف للغاية السيد
رئيس مجلس النواب ثا  ما يحدث في هذا
المكان هو أننا نختار
تسييس حقوق الإنسان